hey guys my name is Jess it is the 20th
of july today and you're watching games
button following the success of Pokemon
go nintendo is now worth more than sony
even though they didn't develop or
publish the game bloomberg reports that
Nintendo's value hit thirty nine point
eight billion on tuesday which stands
above sony 38.3 four billion if numbers
aren't your thing you'll probably still
appreciate the ridiculousness of this
market value chart although nintendo
didn't make pokemon go they do own a
share of the pokemon company who created
the app in collaboration with developer
niantic lab last week and int under
became the most traded company x value
of shares this century in japan as if
losing out to nintendo wasn't bad enough
sony president Shuhei Ishida's twitter
was hacked by a group called our mine
all mine claim to be a security group
and not a hacking group but what they've
done is break into your sheet is account
and post messages reading hey it's our
mine we're testing your security and
you've been hacked by our mine team
visit our website to secure yourself
usually there has since regained control
of his account the same group is
previously targeted the boss of yahoo
and the founder of twitter our line also
claimed responsibility for a recent
pokemon go outage but really how could
you even tell with that one I leave
except are expecting big things from
watchdogs to CEO Guillermo said during
an earnings call that watch dogs too has
the potential to be one of ubisoft's
best-selling games of all time he added
that he's confident in the gameplay and
story advancements the team has made for
the sequel making particular note of the
games more seamless online functionality
and co-op he also said the game has
engaging characters a relevant storyline
inspired by hacker culture and that the
reacted e3 this year was very positive
will be able to make that judgment for
ourselves when watch dogs two releases
on November 15 the ps4 Xone and PC
you should have had to gain spot for
news on how to get like this strange
episode 1 and battlefield 4 DLC for free
and I will see you again tomorrow